about uh automating the causal inference
pipeline from lossless uh microsoft
research take away thank you very much
thanks for inviting me uh as you noticed
like i decided to switch the dough with
my talk uh the main reason was that the
topic that i had chosen is the quiet
sort by now old paper and i thought of
presenting more
some more recent work that i'm uh
that i think will present more
opportunities for collaboration and some
challenges that i find exciting and so
maybe this would bring up topics uh that
you know if you're interested come talk
to me after after the talk
so also that this was at the expense of
presenting a more polished stock so
please excuse any roughness in the in
the presentation
so
okay
so something one thing that is that um
sort of like top of mind for me these
days is that uh we live in an era where
it's so easy to use uh machine learning
almost every decision maker any domain
expert that has access to a data set
uh and an outcome of interest can
construct a machine learning predictive
model to predict the outcome from the
variables that they have
um and so there's all of these uh sort
of like infrastructure and all of this
uh
you know software that
major companies have developed where
basically the advertisement is come with
your data drop it into our automotive
system and then you can predict
and the you know the ease of use of
machine learning has led to also the
ease of misuse where especially with the
advent of a lot of interpretability
tools many times people currently use
the combination of automated machine
learning and interpretability to naively
you know interpret that as causal
inference so for instance one very
widely used interpretability tool out
there is the sub
method and the sub library where you
train an arbitrary predictive model you
pass it through sub and for every
variable you get some direction of how
that variable affects your prediction
and there's been even in internal to
microsoft or we've seen data science
groups uh uh you know about external the
migrants of trying to use these numbers
as being sort of the causal effect of
the variable on the outcome of interest
and this also even led us to write a
blog post with the creator of the sub
library to be cautious when you're when
you're doing that
but there's actually sort of like a good
reason why people are
using automobile plus interpretability
for causal influence and the new
problems that they're that they're
facing that you know machine learning is
able to handle much richer and much more
complex data sets than what traditional
causal inference techniques uh have been
developed for and so if i come to
you with data that has a lot of
variables or maybe unstructured
variables i might get you know a better
you know
a better decision if i use an automated
ml than using like a linear regression
or any other you know a causal inference
approach that is going to make many
simplifying assumptions
and this has led to the uh the
flourishing of this
combination of causal influence and
machine learning discussion machine
learning tool that tries to combine
estimation approaches for machine
learning
and and sort of like the causal
inference pipeline to lead to um sort of
causal machine learning tools that will
allow you to make decisions even with
such a high dimensional complex data
but another big hurdle is that most of
these causal machine learning
technologies focus
particularly on the cervix estimation
part
or the inference part of the causal
inference pipeline
um
but uh unlike predictive modeling if we
want to make this causal influence
accessible to any decision maker out
there
there's so many other components to the
causal inference pipeline that we also
need to automate when we're trying to do
predictive modeling
there are basically three components
three steps you collect your data you do
some estimation some training and then
you keep some out of symbol validation
and you validate on that sample
and maybe now you even have you know
maybe interpret the interpretability
component at the end to try to
understand what did the model learn to
predict
when you're trying to do causal
modelling there are some key aspects
that are rendering this pipeline
uh which we cannot ignore one of them
being the domain assumption elicitation
uh
it is
you know quintessential to be in order
to perform uh sort of uh because i'll
inference that we elicit assumptions
from domain experts on what
relationships are correlated with what
and if they're like unobserved
confounded and and other you know like
assumptions that we do not that the data
cannot tell us
um
moreover when we're going to
interpretability now it's not just
interpreting what the model learned but
also what polish recommendations can we
give to the uh to the decision maker
however now you know since we our
conclusions are based on these
assumptions from the domain experts we
also want to do sensitivity analysis how
our conclusions are changing to
violations of those assumptions
and because you know there's no perfect
analog of out of sample validation for
causal inference it's also very critical
that our estimation also comes with some
form of uncertainty quantification
and finally exactly because there's no
perfect analog of out of sample
validation for causal inference the
ultimate you know like
analog is active data collection so
experimentation right so really the
causal illuminance pipeline is this loop
where you have data you elicit
assumptions you devise some
identification strategy then you do your
estimation and your inference maybe you
do some validation given the assumptions
if you want to do model selection
you recommend some policies you perform
some sensitivity analysis of how these
policies would change if those
assumptions are violated and maybe then
you also recommend to the decision maker
to run some experiment that will better
inform the conclusions right
so these are all of the components that
we need to automate if we really we need
to to move to an automated causal
machine learning system in the same
manner that currently are people people
are using the automated machine learning
systems
and i guess my point is that a lot of
the
focus has been around these components
but there's also so many other
challenges that we need to address if we
want to make causal influence accessible
to any decision maker
the other thing is that i believe that
you know like unlike machine learning
and predictive modeling
for causal inference we cannot really
exclude the human in the loop from this
pipeline there are actually the one
crucial step where
i believe we always have a human in the
loop is in the assumption elicitation
and another step where in most
applications we have a human loop is the
in the implementation of the experiment
right
maybe in in cases where in digital
experimentation where it's not high
stakes maybe there we could have
automated experimentation but in most
critical scenarios someone will need to
look at the experiment you want to run
and vet it and see that it's something
that it's actually
feasible to run
due to maybe safety constraints ethical
constraints fairness constraints
and so all of these there are all of
these open challenges that sort of like
i'm
i'm very excited about thinking in the
future
that
the estimation and influence is only a
small part of this whole
automation
um some of them have been more addressed
than others
for instance
you know as i said
identification strategies we have you
know based on causal graphs generic
identification strategies
but you know for instance incorporating
non-graphical restrictions
i have not found like a genetic approach
where i give you a causal graph and also
several other restrictions then you
automatically give me an identification
strategy
um or
you know um there's been some you know
like experimental validation and some
theoretical work on
proxies for cause for good losses for
causal modelling
and uh some work on policy
recommendations but less about
these other quantities over here
for instance i think one very
underexplored area is
how do we elicit assumptions from the
domain experts
the current approaches out there is
basically ask the domain expert to give
you a causal graph but if i have likes
even 30 variables or 20 variables
you know like the cognitive burden of
providing a causal graph for all of
those variables is so large that many
people who just not use causal inference
just because you ask them to define a
causal graph
but for many causal questions it's not
even needed to define the whole causal
graph in order to devise an
identification strategy
so one question is you know can we
devise interactive
like elicitation protocols
where we elicit the minimal amount of
information that we need
in order to
come up with an identification strategy
and uh another you know
topic that i'll talk a bit more
extensively uh in this talk
is uh the fact that once you start
automating some pipeline uh you also
start having problems with the uh
cleanliness of your data so if someone
comes with an arbitrary data set to you
and drops it into your your your
pipeline
most of those data sets will be
corrupted in some manner um if you're in
a critical scenario maybe those datasets
will be corrupted in an adversarial
manner so we also need to think very
carefully about robustness to data
corruption and maybe adversarial attacks
when we within the causal inference
pipeline
and another topic that i'll talk about
today which is sort of more developed is
how do we automate
the inference how do we automate with
the inference uh process when we use
machine learning for the estimation part
so i won't talk any about any of these
other challenges but if you're
interested in any in collaborating any
of these please
talk to me afterwards
so in the interest of presenting
something more technical i'll focus on
some recent work that we did on
robustness
and
causal inference and automated the
biasing
in causal inference
any questions
so the first part is uh
it's based on a recent work that we did
with uh drew brocky who is a student a
phd student at mit
and it's about this topic of how do we
fend against
corruption adversarial corruption
in our data sets when we're doing some
causal estimation
and
our goal
is to
perform automated and theoretically
grounded outlier removal
that can lead with that can deal with
corrupted data for instance maybe to
poor data collection or adversarial
attacks
and also mitigate a bit the problem of
drawing conclusions from small fractions
of your data
there's been some very recent
very interesting work recently
that showed that many of the conclusions
from high-profile for instance empirical
economics papers
could be reverted if you solely remove
or change a bit some small fraction of
your data right and so your conclusions
are very sensitive to the small fraction
of your data
but if you use
some of the classical approaches in
causal estimation
and so this motivated us to study
uh causal estimation within the strong
contamination model
which is a very strong notion of
corruption but allows you to
you know like fend against these types
of problems
so what is a strong connomination
basically says you have samples drawn
iad but then an adversary counts
and arbitrarily alters an epsilon
fraction of the samples in an arbitrary
month
and what are the good you know what what
we want from robust estimators uh is
that first of all they're
computationally tractable
they robust a constant fraction of
outliers so not just asymptotic uh
theorems as epsilon goes to zero
and that we get some quantity defined at
error guarantees without dimension
dependence as for any epsilon and for
any sample size
uh a lot of these are not achieved by
the more classical work in robust
statistics but there has been a
uh
you know
very rich recent literature in the
computational learning theory community
that tries to address all of these daisy
derata
for problems such as mean and covariance
estimation linear regression and risk
minimization
and so the goal of
our work is to study a much more general
framework that would
encompass causal estimation
and that framework is the framework of
estimating parameters defined via
conditional
via moment restrictions right
so
many causal estimation problems can be
formed as finding a parameter
that satisfies some moment condition
which looks like
if i take an expectation of my data
coming from the distribution this moment
vector g has to be equal to zero when
evaluated at the truth theta
and you know one concrete example is
linear regression
where this is the implicit moment when
you do square loss minimization
and another prominent example is
instrumental variable regression which
is basically the same as linear
regression but instead of multiplying by
the thing that you're regressing on you
multiply by the instrument
so even though you know linear
regression you can formulate it as risk
minimization and then you could apply
prior techniques in the computational
learning theory community iv regression
doesn't fall into that
class of problems but falls into this
larger class of moment problems
so our goal was to
adapt those techniques so that we have
sort of like this this data for uh the
setting of generalized method of moment
estimation
so when you have this method of moment
when you have these moment conditions
the
one standard estimator that you're
trying to minimize
some rewaited violation
of your of your moment so some norm of
your of your of your moment restrictions
so even though this uh general methods
of moments estimator for some
appropriate choice of the weighting
matrix is statistically efficient and
also can be implemented
under further conditions in a
computational efficient manner it's not
outlier robust and many of you for
instance the examples that that the
paper
was showing was examples where the
estimation was happening through a gm
estimation
so our results are basically the
following at the higher level we provide
a robust five gmm algorithm which
achieves recovery error that scales with
root of the epsilon fraction in the
epsilon strong contamination model for
any for any constant epsilon that is
small enough but not going to zero
and such that our algorithm is runs in
polynomial time and has polynomial
sample complexity
and to achieve that we will need some
conditions on our on our uh moments
which are sort of like regularity
conditions you know the the parameters
should be strongly identified by the
moments not just weekly
the uh
there's been bounded variance uh in the
noise and the grading of the moments um
uh
you're
without the extreme corruption you
should be well specified so your moments
should be holding
and the moments should be should satisfy
some ellipses condition with respect to
the
parameter
um is there any condition that this kind
of
um
the the moment function that you're
trying to admit to men to minimize
that it is like con convex in the in the
data
there's no uh assumption but if it's
closely related to the strong
identification
uh it will also alter whether you know
you can solve the gmm problem
efficiently or not for the prominent
example would be you know like the
moment will be linear in theta and then
you'll get uh
but yeah so sometimes you know the
stronger identification sometimes is
coupled with computational efficiency
but not generically like in the general
problem
and in fact you know in the general in
the wrong you're actually trying to find
a critical point of their norm right so
you don't really need to minimize the
norm of the violation because the
critical point is a point where where
the moments will be satisfied so that
suffices so you know you can even do
like critical point yeah
what is that what does that mean then
with that
well i guess
if you're going to tell us about strong
identifiability then i'll wait to ask
that i'll state in the context of the ib
example yeah
like the strongest typically also uh
allows us to
argue robustness so it's not just about
computation but allows our group
and we'll enter into
our robustness rates
our theorem is a two-part theorem first
we saw some
recovery bounds
for general moment condition problems
assuming that the empirical distribution
of the samples of of the true samples of
the corrupted samples satisfies all of
those conditions and then we saw that
for particular applications that are uh
very popular applications of the of the
gmn framework such as iv regression and
some nonlinear version of eye regression
those assumptions are satisfied with
high probability
under population level assumptions
so how does our algorithm look like it's
basically a filtering algorithm and it's
based on uh a recent work in the in the
cold community uh
that's uh that's called the sever
algorithm which was applied to loss
minimization to risk communication
so the basic idea behind these filtering
approaches uh is the following if you
have two distributions
um
that are uh
within a small with an epsilon tv
distance with each other and that holds
between the uncorrupted and the
corrupted because we can only
corrupt epsilon fraction of the samples
then for any such epsilon close to
random variables either
their
covariance operators should be large
or otherwise their mean is small with
that within that bound
so either
you're good enough because you care
about means
and you don't need to feel that anything
or if you're not good enough
and you need to filter some things
you
you're gonna need to filter you you know
there's an evidence here so you know
like the things that you need to filter
have a large covariance in some
direction
yeah
so right so it must be that if this
difference in means that you care about
is large
uh
then it must be that
because you need to filter you need to
filter out stuff then that stuff that
you need to filter will have some uh
large covariance in some direction of
the covariance operator
and so what the filtering algorithm does
basically says
you're given some target initial set of
samples that you believe are uncorrupted
you're going to calculate the empirical
covariance of those samples right
you're going to find the largest angular
vector of those samples
and then you're going to look for every
sample what is the projection of that
vector on that largest eigenvector
and you're going to try to cut off
points that have a very large absolute
value of that projection right things
that have a large projection of that
largest egg in vector you're going to
cut off if it happens that you don't
that there are not many things that are
sort of outliers in that direction you
don't cut off anything and this you know
like
intuition here is going to give you that
that your means are close to each other
so that's the basic intuition behind
filtering and then what we're going to
do is we're going to apply this
intuition to the gmn problem
our algorithm is similar to the server
problem for his communication but has an
extra step because now our loss which is
this gmm loss is not just an empirical
risk it's the norm of some vector of
empirical uh
moments and so we're going to need sort
of two filtering steps one that tries to
filter the
jacobian of the of the of the moments
and another tries to filter the moments
themselves okay
so
this uh filtering
um which is probably more
general
like about the technique
but it seems like i'm filtering based
only on the second moments
but the corruption
i could do any kind of wacky thing so
what's kind of the intuition that the
second moments are enough to detect
corruption assuming that your true data
has bonded to second moments because i'm
on the combines of the true data and
that's why it allows you to detect the
ic the ic so if i
okay you're going to make assumptions
that this the true has a bounded by
sigma and then you're gonna
so this is the you know the difference
between this concrete algorithm and the
prior work for examination we need to
fill the next steps but the you know the
and in the end with these two synthetic
steps we can show uh our general method
theorem
and then we can apply to for instance
the iv regression the concrete
assumptions that we're going to need for
iv regression is first that the
instruments are valid um you know when
you subtract the
uh
the
outcome from the causal effect
the residual is going to be mean zero
condition on the instrument
these noise
these
residuals should have bounded variants
uh this is the strong instrument uh
assumption that the sort of covariance
between the instrument and the treatment
should be lower bounded by some lambda
in terms of minimum making value
the covalence of the instrument and the
treatment should be upper bounded by
some
l
uh we need some assumption between the
l4 and the l2 moment of those random
variables which is typical in this
literature and called the 42 hyper
contractivity
and another more benign assumption on
the bounded large moments and subject to
all of these assumptions we can get a
rate that scales with root epsilon and
over here you're going to get constants
that depend
on on the bounds on the variance that
you assumed
and the strength of the instrument
um
and the algorithm that that's going to
come out of the general
purpose machinery is also going to be
polynomial uh time
in terms of computation
so that is one of our main results in
this in this paper and then we also try
to see how it performs in practice
compared to more existing techniques for
doing robust statistics in the in the
context of iv regression
so here we looked at for example the
case of trying to estimate heterogeneous
treatment effects with instruments and
for simplicity you make a linear
heterogeneity assumption that your
heterogeneity is linear in in the
covariates that you have and then it
becomes really a linear iv regression
problem where the number of moments that
you have corresponds to the number of
variables that you have
plus one
so these are the moment restrictions we
do a synthetic experiment where we have
20 such characteristics 10 000 samples
and we scale the corruption over here
this is what our
gmm server algorithm would would get as
an estimation error l2 recovery error
another prominent
prior work from the 80s in in the
context of vibration and more recently
was also uh
there were there's been some more recent
work on it is to view iv as a two-stage
linear regression which is one standard
approach and instead of running
two-stage linear regression you do you
run two-stage robust regression so
hyper-regression
and we see that these two states have
regression is also very sensitive to
this epsilon contamination most of the
results in that literature are only
asymptotic as epsilon goes to uh to zero
and provide the
guarantees that as epsilon goes to zero
get consistency but there's no finite
epsilon guarantee and also the vanilla
ivr would also be very large
another experiment that we run was a
more
semi-synthetic experiment where we take
this very classical data in labor
economics on that studies the
uh the effect of education on wages
and there we we took that data and
basically added corrupted data to that
data set and and tried to see how
standard iv regression would perform and
how our gmm
server regression would perform
we actually did the corruption where if
you
carefully you know we did a sort of like
an adversarial attack where the standard
iv would would negate
the effect of the
uh
of the treatment if you start if you
apply another iv
but our gmm server would would predict
an effect which matches
the uh the effect on the uncorrupted
data if you were to run iv on the
uncorrupted data
so uh
this is a more like you know empirical
application that
even though there's there were a lot of
constants in the theorem it actually
works well in practice and and better
than other approaches to robust
estimation
so that was
what i wanted to say about this this
this result and one major open question
that i believe
arises is how do we do inference when we
try and also defend against such
outliers
so here you have a lot of filtering
through your algorithm and that will
definitely alter the distributional
properties of your estimator and so how
can we provide confidence interval if we
do these filtering steps
um and this is you know like a generic
problem when you know typically these
filtering steps are done by a data
scientist or a statistician who tries to
clean up the data
and
and find out liars
and i guess the the point of this work
is that we need to automate that even
that process and once we automate that
process through some algorithms maybe we
can also automate the inference process
afterwards given that we know uh how
you're filtering your data to fend
against outliers
so that was that that part the other
part i want to talk about briefly is
about automated biasing
of generic machine learning with generic
machine learning
and this is joint work with uh victor
chernozukov with ninui uh rahu and uh
victor quintas martinez all from mit
and this again deals with uh you know
moment estimation problems
but now apart from the more classical uh
moment estimation conditions that i was
talking to in the previous vignette
here
we're also going to add the next
component to our moment conditions
we're going to add these nuisance
functions we're going to add the
functions that we need to estimate from
data
but we don't really care about
and many problems in causal difference
boil down to estimation problems that
look like that where you also have a
nuisance component
even in our previous section you know we
had the coefficient theta that was in
front of the treatment but we also had
the offset beta that we needed to
estimate
and for instance some leading examples
when you're trying to estimate average
treatment effects
to estimate the average treatment effect
you need to estimate this big regression
problem where you want to regress your
outcome on the treatment and all of the
observable confounders
and if those are are many confounders
this is a very hard regression problem
but you don't really care about the
regression problem what you hear about
is the average of these contrasts
uh or average policy effect where you
know you are going to treat or not treat
people based on some
candidate policy and your goal is to
estimate what is the value of that
policy
or the average derivative when you have
a continuous treatment like a dose or a
price
where you want to estimate the average
marginal effect of that price and
expectation over
the treatments that you observed in the
data
now because many times we're faced with
hard regression problems over here you
might want to use machine learning to
estimate those regression
functions
but machine learning will lead to
regularized and biased estimates and so
naively plugging in those estimates into
these equations will lead to
non-asymptotically robust and
non-asymptotically normal and also
non-robust
uh
estimates of the target parameters that
you care about and this has been a large
body of work in the um in the
semi-parametric inference literature of
how we uh
sort of like reduce uh that um
error from those nuisance components and
how do we get confidence intervals and
inference despite using machine learning
for those
components and the high-level intuition
is that instead of doing a plug-in uh
approach to your original moments you're
going to debias your moments so you're
going to add the biasing term to your
moments that
will relate to the bias of your
regression function
so
say for instance for simplicity now that
our moments have a very special form
that the parameter we care about is the
expected
value of some moment function
that depends on the regression function
all of the moments that we
represent the previous slide fall into
this category
and that this function is is in the form
of some regression y conditional on x
then you know one result in the
semiparametric inference literature that
the biased version of that moment
condition is of the of the following
form
uh
oh so this would be a plus here
um
add to your original moment some
function of x
and the residual of the g that you
estimated with the target thing that it
wants to predict so if your
g was biased then this residual over
here would not be mean zero and so you
would be adding a bias term to your
moment condition
and then the main question is what is
this a of x what function should we add
here in order to still estimate the same
quantity theta over here and in order to
really achieve the biasing of our
original moment and the function that
you need to put in here is what is known
as the risk representer of this linear
functional so if your moment is linear
in g then this expectation over here is
a linear functional of g
and every linear functional subject
regularity conditions is going to have
an inner product representation
so it's going to have a a representation
of this form for some function a
and this is called the risk representer
theorem
and the
function that you need to put in here is
exactly the risk representer that comes
out of the representers here
okay
the traditional approach to the biasing
has been
characterized what the there is
representer looks like for the target
moment that you care about
and then once you see how it looks like
maybe it corresponds to estimating some
other nuisance function like a
propensity
or a density
and then
estimate that and plug it in your is and
anti-bias so that's the more traditional
approach to the biasing
and
you know like for instance you know for
the average treatment effect you can
show that this is there is representer
which leads to the doubly robust
estimator
where p here is the propensity the
probability of that the treatment takes
value equals one
for average policy effect it's a similar
sort of like inverse propensity
quantity and for the average derivative
is the derivative of the log of the
density of the treatment conditional and
the confounders
and so one uh line of work in the in the
recent years uh
pioneered by this paper of chernozook of
new enzyme
and also smuggler at michigan robins is
whether we can circumvent this
characterization
and
directly estimate a
simply having some oracle access to the
moment
and you can see how that is useful when
trying to think broadly in this
automating the causal inference pipeline
in that if our moment comes in some sort
of black box manner from some
identification algorithm we don't want
to
every time go in there and do some
analytical calculation and define what
there is represent there is and the bias
it if we only if we could only you know
calculate what this represent this
represent there is
just you having oracle access to the
moment it will be very useful in
automating the whole pipeline
can i ask oh on the last slide so i've
seen this uh technique before from the
previous one
yes yes the the the d bias
moment but can you remind me is the
reason that we do this to get
uh these doubly robust
rates is this the main reason or there
are other reasons that we do that's the
main reason yeah to get like you can uh
so once you do buy as you get that the
error of g enters in a second-order term
uh in this situation you can even get
that it's the product of ang that
matters of the error of a engine that
matters so that's yeah that's the thing
about you yeah yeah let me show i was on
the same page okay thanks
and so that was but then that prior work
was focusing on particular types of
representations for that there is
representing particularly linear
representations where you have some
sieve and you do some l1 penalize the
estimation for the visual presenter and
so the motivation of this work was can
we use generic machine learning for a
learning that is represented and not
just sims seeds
not just linear representations
uh so first you know like one paper that
we wrote on this genetic
estimation approach was the adversarial
approach where basically we know we know
that our risk representative needs to
satisfy this continuum of moment
restrictions that for any test function
g your moment needs to be equal to this
inner product
and so you can go from that to an
adversarial loss where if you have a
candidate risk representer you can try
to maximize the moment violation
penalizing some
second moment of the test function
and this will still be identifying your
risk representer
and so here you you just need oracle
access to your moment m
and you know just solely of that solely
using that you can if you solve the min
max problem over some function class a
and some function class g you can get
there is representer
and that in that paper we showed how
this estimator that comes out of this
min max
approach achieves uh estimation rates
for there is representer that scale with
what's known as the critical radius of
the function classes which is a tight
measure of complexity for that was being
studied for square losses and here we
also applied to this mean type of min
max losses and what is rg and ra these
are
penalizations so typically this would be
the norm of g and the norm of a squared
for some definition of a norm and these
penalizations will allow you also to not
just scale with the critical radius but
also with the norm of the true risk
representer which is unknown so if if
you don't add those you can still get
quantities but we'll have a
worst case norm dependence in the
leading term if you add
penalizations then you'll
you'll scale automatically with the norm
of the truth is represented
so that was you know the first paper we
wrote on genetic ml for there is
representer
[Music]
so g is like think of it as a symmetric
so
of generality
if you find the g that this negative
violation is negative you could also do
the minus g and it's positive so think
of this as the maximizing the moment
violation
and you want to find the a that
minimizes the maximum moment violation
that was one result later actually we
also found that you
you could
you don't need the min max
approach to the generic machine learning
that you can also find
so that there is representation is the
minimizer of the following laws where
you uh take the
square of there is representative
subtract two times the uh the moment and
the intuition is that basically in the
population limit this quantity over here
is just going to be the product and so
by completing the square the loss that
you're actually minimizing in the
population limit is equal to the mean
squared error loss with respect to the
unknown a naught so even though you
don't know what a naught is
by minimizing this loss you're
essentially minimizing the mean squared
error
in the population limit with respect to
that a naught and so you can also show
similar critical radius results for
arbitrary function classes by minimizing
this this loss function over here
now relation between the two i still
like uh haven't found like the concrete
which one is better to do in practice
they give
comparable results uh one argument in
favor of the adversarial approach is
that it really tries to minimize the
moment violation which is what enters
into your bias component when you
analyze the error so directly targets
the bias of your final estimator but on
the other hand is computationally much
more uh much harder to
to solve and so you know this is simpler
but
maybe you'll get a lower bias with the
adversarial estimator but we haven't run
extensive experiments to understand
whether the finite sample differences of
the two approaches
so here for instance this is an example
theorem that we get for the this loss
minimization approach
uh where you know one key property that
i didn't mention thus far is that we
need the moment
function to satisfy what's known as mean
squared continuity so it's a form of
continuity of your moment function but
it's slightly stronger than being
continuous with respect to the the
nuisance parameter it has to be mean
squared continuous and many examples
satisfy this but
that's one key regularity property that
we need and
solely based on this property we can get
the rate where you know the leading term
is this critical radius and this is just
the bias if you're optimizing over a
space of functions that do not contain
the true risk representer
and we can also go beyond linear models
where you know instead of subtracting
this represented for the moment you
first take the derivative of the
nonlinear moment with respect to the
nuisance and then apply there is theorem
to that and then
other biasing term but this will satisfy
similar the biasing properties but
weaker so it's going to be a locally
de-biased moment
and then
by the way how much time do i have do
you have like uh two minutes or
two minutes yeah
so
you can even go beyond uh linear moments
and achieve sort of like a
val asymptotically valid inference with
generic ml
and then we also try to uh implement
those approaches with neural networks or
random forests uh and one sort of like
more heuristic improvement that that we
found when implementing that which led
to
another work where we really uh
dive into this uh
heuristic improvement is applying
multitasking
where now since our risk representer is
the minimization of this loss maybe we
can jointly train for the risk
representer and the
uh regression problem and learner
presentations that are good for both
of those regression of those functions
that we're trying to learn and the
intuition is that you know essentially
if you're
trying to solve such a
moment problem uh you really don't need
to control for all of the confounders
you only need to control for the uh risk
representer
in order to be unbiased so as long as
you're controlling for the risk
representer you're going to get an
unbiased estimate but you know of course
controlling explicitly for all the rest
will lead you to a better and more
efficient a more lower variance estimate
but just from the purpose of unbiased
you just need to control for the risk
representer and so as long as you have a
good representation that can represent
there is representer and that's what
goes into your regression function
that's still good enough for getting an
unbiased final estimate
and so you can think for instance
training in neural net where you have
some initial representation layers that
spit out there is represented that
minimizes this loss and then also that
same representation goes into a
regression
loss
and this is what we applied both for uh
neural nets and random forests where for
random forests you can couple the tree
structure
and we get sort of like better
performance in some classical benchmark
data sets like this infant health
development program that even beats the
plug-in estimation approach where you
explicitly know there is representing a
plug-it in you can get even better
results with our direct sort of like
release estimation
framework so
that's that and with that uh you know we
also applied to some real data there we
don't see big differences between the
different methods whether you do the
adversarial the non-adversarial the
plug-in or not plug-in the estimates
that you get
for instance in a another prominent
example that many people use which is
the 401k example and the eligibility on
on net financial assets over uh
on foreign eligibility on financial
assets over the horizon of about two
years so this survey goes maybe more to
the stability that uh that being you uh
once that all of these things are giving
the similar
effects so maybe this is the right
effect over here and similarly we
applied it to another uh uh
application where the the treatment is
continuous and then we have to deal with
this much more complex average
derivative uh estimation
uh another open question over here that
i think is is
is interesting is going beyond
regression nuisance functions and
general causal graphs and doing
automated biasing for general causal
graphs
and with that i'd like to conclude and
thank you very much for your attention
yeah so if you have like a say you know
a continuous variable and a general
causal graph and you do some
identification strategy where which
depends on uh on some regression
problems then does it always fit in our
in our current framework i'm not sure
for instance if you go to the dynamic
treatment that's a concrete setting
where i don't know where current
techniques do not handle it so if you
have like some identification strategy
for the dynamic regime
then you might you know like
needs more more work on automated bias
so but what okay but i ca do you have an
example of like a simple problem that
uses some a business function if this is
a regression like density ratio or
something uh okay the one example will
be if it's like a nested integration
function so the regression function
functions it depends on another
regression function depends on another
integration function you mean like
decomposition yes like in general
mutation so if you have a g formula with
a nested set of regressions then you
know
got it that's a very concrete question
that
so
yes so
you can apply this representative
formulation and then instead of like
you know like uh
finding the average of this
subtract some theta of x and minimize
the square loss and that would lead to
what i was going to talk about in the
prior
presentation of orthogonal statistical
learning this would be an orthogonal
loss and you'll get second order effects
from the risk representer and your g on
the estimation of the k th estimate
similar to how you get for like the dr
learner
this would be a generalization of the dr
learner
can you compare your x measure with the
double robot
like under some of those minds well
asymptotic equations or something so
asymptotically they are the same it's
more like uh
do you get like a
better error by directly minimizing the
square loss for there is versus
minimizing the logistic loss and then
plugging in
so i think that would be the difference
and you see that the difference in
performance here where this we solve the
random force classifier with laggy thing
we get the mean square there that is
huge and if you do like a w bus with our
reset presenter you get a much smaller
in this semi-synthetic experiment
so it's a better maybe loss function for
training your classifier
all right let's thank the speaker one
more time
you